was allegedly like this big and
allegedly the whole thing was like was
like this like was allegedly this big
now we sound suspicious imagine there's
a detective watching this from your case
back then going got
[Music]
him is anybody here still use Snapchat
at all oh sometimes only with friends
though yeah is it just to have like
conversations that you want not on the
record like like send no it's literally
the fastest way to like send uh like
nudes no I'm just kidding stupid it's
just literally my girlfriend's just
sending random like random videos and
random pictures and that's it for no
reason yeah okay I use it at all yeah I
feel like I don't really meet a lot of
people that use it anymore I just flash
my wife now I don't really send her any
dick pics anymore you flash your wife on
Snapchat no just in
person I feel like once you reach 21 and
you still have Snapchat like you're in
embarrassment I still have Snapchat I
just don't use it I still use Snapchat
my bad half embarrassing so there's a
there's 's a big law shoot right now a
bunch UH 60 parents have banded together
to uh Sue Snapchat cuz all the kids are
buying drugs yeah wow cuz every story we
talk about Snapchat they're always the
kids are buying drugs from drug yeah but
not only are they buying drugs but the
kids these are the parents of kids who
have died don't yell at me dude I didn't
know I didn't know dude I thought they
were buying peret I didn't know they
were buying no they're buying they're
buying all kinds of different narcotics
but then these are the ones that like
are fit in lace of course and then you
know their tolerance is nowhere yeah
they're not ready for that handle the
the Big Daddy stuff I thought they were
sending underage dick piics n they don't
care about that just Li bro but um yeah
so they're they're suing now and uh
because Snapchat I guess there's an
algorithm that's in play for everything
so even if it's something illegal it'll
the algo will still treat it like it's
just a thing so if you're a person who's
buying drugs on Snapchat from different
dealers you have a higher rate of
finding other dealers that's cool oh
convenient drug Al that is a good
algorithm it works that's good Tech at
least it's a fair one so that's why now
there's an actual ability to to sue them
because they're like you you can't just
sue them for using the platform for you
know bad things but now they're like
well now we can prove that your app has
made it easier to
buy that's kind of shitty because they
didn't mean for that to happen they're
just trying to serve you things that you
like but then it happened to be drugs
and illegal drugs right is it really
their fault there's that what's his name
that Bo Burnham he had this like whole
speech about like why do you think that
there's an app that exists where me
that's targeted for 13-year-olds where
messages disappear after you send them
and it was like I forget what he went on
to say but that just sparked a thought
in my mind where it was like the app is
marketed towards children damn that is
pretty rough sus like it's like oh we
don't want your messages to be seen by
anyone afterwards like that is really
sus yeah you're right right it's a sus
app overall you do that on Instagram on
vanish mode that is true but then does
the other person know they do right yeah
when you do vanish mode does it actually
vanish or is it still yeah vanishes it's
yeah it's basically you're turning on
Snapchat for your Instagram chat what
about Google because yeah but isn't it
still being saved in a database for a
certain period of time accessible to
certain people I think certain people
can access or whatever you know such a
like a high level of like you got to
investigate into like yeah you know what
about the pictures like Snapchat where
you can do it but it doesn't you can't
keep it be real are you talking about be
no like on Instagram you send a photo
like if you send a dickpic or whatever
but then it's not it's it it does only
20 like what after you open it it's done
can't they just save it or screen cat
they'll know it'll tell you it'll show
you it'll be like they screenshotted you
oh you know back back when Snapchat had
like you can screenshot it but it
wouldn't tell you that you screenshotted
it no way in the beginning like a little
bit yeah yeah the good old days I
remember the [__] Snapchat when it
would snitch on you about who you were
snapping the best friends bro that [__]
ruined my life true cuz you would if you
don't use Snapchat and then you snap
someone like twice in a row then they're
your best friend they're your best
friend and then all of a sudden you're
get a phone call why is this person why
are you snapping this person that's like
Myspace days man that's scary top best
friends but Myspace you got to pick who
is your best friend Snapchat would tell
everyone like look look who who they're
snapping who's
talking Look So speaking to the anyone
in the room who's a former narcotics
pedler it's not just you it's um I I saw
what do you think about selling drugs on
Snapchat is that like it's the best
place to do it pretty if you want new
customers cuz if you have your or like
already base then like why are you using
SnapChat maybe to meet up or like
arrange it so you don't have a phone but
you have a burner phone so why I don't I
don't understand maybe if you're like
retail meaning like you're selling the
new or or you're just every day like
having people pick up but once you go to
wholesale you already have your people
that you sell to would you consider it a
dis honorable act that it was like no I
think it's genius dude when I was in
Vietnam um one of the most genius sales
I saw was uh on Tinder so I matched up
with this girl and we were chatting and
then they're like oh you like smoking
and and drinking and whatever do you
like smoke weed and I'm like yeah he's
like oh do you want to buy some or
whatever I'm like oh interesting and
then after uh there was like actually
bro I'm a guy sorry if I wasted your
time but they're like if you want like
I'm out here in Vietnam you
you know and then I was like oh he's
like you're from LA right he goes can
you can you get me a connect and I'm all
like oh that's interesting and I'm like
I'm out of the game completely but that
that that's a nice way for you to you
know find an introduction yeah sweet
plug entrepreneurship hey I seen I've
seen a Tinder he got banned from Tinder
but I seen this guy that made candles he
had a candle business and he went on
Tinder and it was just pictures of his
candles and it was like SWAT like so if
you would SWAT it was he was literally
using Tinder to Market his candles
that's [__] and then he got banned
but he made hella sales off of Tinder
that's [__] so smart that's so they
like your candle damn that's so funny
that's so wholesome to do that I thought
I was talking to a ABG that lives in
Vietnam and I'm all like wow you know
English being some Eastern European guy
that overstate his [__] and he's
trying to find a way to get connects for
herb he goes I need wholesale you know I
not good [__] here but you're from
California so you dropped them after
that you never like helped them out with
none of that you didn't link with him to
you you guys a link up no damn the idea
of like it sucks because I I feel like
if you're selling through snapchat
you're mainly going after kids right
yeah or no cuz like AR most who's 20
who's older than 21 no but you know what
Snapchat is an old thing like I feel
like people these days don't like kids
don't be using like people like like
they do cuz if you go on Snapchat SP if
you go on their version of Tik Tok the
content is so childish true and then you
read the comments on there and it's like
yeah these are kids that are on this
[__] I just think that it's for like
like kids use it yeah there's a whole
thing there now where like the cpms are
super high if you post content dude I
was posting for hella long trying to get
that [__] to crack but my [__] is
alcohol so like they would just take my
[__] down all the time too bad it's not
drugs man yeah too bad it wasn't Molly
and fentol sorry sorry Snapchat damn
yeah a lot of people started moving
their content to Snapchat for that
reason that is a weird way to connect
though cuz back I mean the first way was
Silk Road remember that yeah and then
people would get it in the mail that way
oh Black Market [__] yeah I still do
that on the dark web yeah have you ever
been on the dark web I don't even know
what it looks like dark dark mode dark
mode it's like a browser but it's like
dark mode like you know Spider-Man just
imagine
Venom you had to you had to down I
forgot what the [__] tour you had to get
tour yeah yeah you have to get a whole
other like Standalone did you peek
around right I we used to um we used to
in high school we used to buy whole
sheets of acid and then we were just off
tour oh my God that's crazy you know
what's funny is um back in the day so I
I don't know if it was legal in Canada
but you know they have a whole growing
culture that was Superior to California
at the time and um I was on a straight
up just website and they would show you
all these different kinds of weed seeds
that you can buy MH right I
[__]
basically they the way that they did it
is you don't put your own credit card
you like buy like money order and then
you send the money order in I put this
dude's address on there for Mr Arthur
Baker Arthur Baker yeah I just said I
just put the name Mr Arthur Baker and I
bought all these seeds and I had it sent
to his house and he goes Joe your
package is here and I [__] got it and
then we were like all scared cuz like at
the time the cops would just if there's
like a delivery or whatever they would
just stake out the house but then but
when it arrived we just left it there
with a different name we just left it in
the mailbox for a couple of days to see
if like there was anybody watching and
then bar was like all right I think you
could take it now so I grabbed it went
home and [__] started growing weed oh
my God yeah but now it's like not even
illegal right this is where we was like
Co having cocaine yeah like
2008 7
I think it was way even before JK might
have been 2004 something did he tell you
he was going to use your address yeah
did he tell you that's funny if he
didn't but it was crazy though cuz that
was like the beginning of all that [__]
like it was like wow I actually got weed
seeds from Canada I still feel like why
don't I just buy actual weed back then I
mean I wanted to grow my own strain and
all nerdy about it you were a con ofur
yeah wait did you actually grow some
good weed I got lazy halfway through
just hard it no it's very hard you need
like a whole greenhouse and [__] it I
don't think it ever flowered you had
like a whole like hydronic system frame
expensive too especially back then bro
we grew one plant at our house in monter
park and then when we had dry it that
allegedly that [__] stank a whole
[__] house allegedly had a whole
framing system we did we did and it
didn't flow allegedly allegedly it never
I'm talking about irrigation and
everything that was like irrigation was
allegedly like this big and allegedly
the whole thing was like was like like
was allegedly this thing now he sound
suspicious imagine there's a detective
watching this from your case back then
going got him they said allegedly move
in move in move in I was he I mean
that's tough growing plants is tough I
kill weed so like like actual just like
weed you know allegedly my boy was
growing an entire weed plant while he
lived with his parents in his closet we
had like um like one of those like
hydroponic like it's almost like a
zipper closet now it's all like you
could buy the whole set we had to go to
Home Depot and build that [__] probably
on Amazon now I still think buying that
type of thing on dark web was that was
like the peanuts like the crazy stuff
people were buying were like Assassin
card blanks or the machines that can
copy that's cool yeah that can read like
like account info or they'll just buy
stolen credit cards and that shit's way
crazier to me you buy human organs you
can't smoke that stuff you know if I
could redo my my criminal years again I
would definitely do scamming into
Financial crime yeah Financial
crime much more money yeah you'll just
get a stop
it that's true man charge it especially
back then and like with the credit card
scamming it's like the the credit card
company is paying for that right not not
the person you're stealing from if they
notice yeah yeah so it's like [__] the
system it's not like yeah get them like
if you don't notice that someone's
scamming you then you're rich
enough that's true and that happens all
the time with people but don't do it
don't allegedly just kidding news
careful Bo is a brand just kidding news
is the man of smart people the people of
just kidding news careful boys they are
very smart just kidding news the number
one podcast in the
[Music]
world